[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSHUA HUNT: Thank you.
So I want to begin with a
little exercise in imagination.
I want you guys to imagine, if
you can, what a huge scandal
it might be if "The New
York Times" discovered
that the CEO of Google
had been quietly paying
$40,000 a year directly towards
the salary of the president
of a major American public
research university.
I think there would
probably be a lot of outrage
over a story like that.
I think there would be headlines
about unchecked corporate power
and overreach in Silicon Valley.
And I think journalists
would begin reporting on
whether or not the president
of this hypothetical university
might have done things, made
decisions, or crafted policy
that was more in favor
of Google's interests
than the interests of his
faculty or his students.
After all, this
hypothetical university
has some very lucrative
business dealings with Google
in this imaginary scenario.
Now we're going to imagine
something even more concerning.
The university
president that we're
imagining runs a nonprofit
organization that's
dedicated to funding research to
find a cure for a disease that
has already killed two of his
daughters and that will kill--
he's told by doctors-- will
kill his last living daughter.
And it turns out
the CEO of Google
has been secretly giving
money to this nonprofit
directly, sometimes $1 million
a year, sometimes $2 million
a year, directly towards this
nonprofit organization that
is doing good work,
but that is directly
benefiting the president of
this university in a very
personal capacity.
These financial
gifts are secret,
even though the
university president
is in charge of a
public institution
and even though he
is supposed to be--
even though his
dealings are supposed
to be open to public scrutiny.
And now the most
alarming part of all,
a member of this university
president's own family--
sorry, household-- a member
of this university president's
household has come forward and
said that this public servant
once took sides
against his own student
body and his own faculty simply
because the CEO that was giving
all this money to his
nonprofit organization
said the flow of
funds would stop
if he didn't put an
end to these protests
on campus, which were aimed
at highlighting his company's
poor human rights
record overseas.
This is the part
where we can stop
relying on our imagination,
because the company was not
Google, but Nike.
The university was
not hypothetical.
It was the University of Oregon.
The university
president was a man
named Dave Frohnmayer, a former
attorney general of Oregon
whose face you might recognize
if you watched the documentary
"Wild Wild Country" on Netflix.
All of this really happened.
And it began unfolding
about two decades ago,
two and a half decades
ago, after Oregonians
passed a really crippling piece
of legislation called Ballot
Measure 5, which was aimed at
slashing property taxes, which
up until that point had done
most of the heavy lifting
in terms of funding public
education in Oregon.
This pitted K
through 12 education,
public K through 12 education,
against public higher education
in Oregon, and it led Dave
Frohnmayer and the University
of Oregon to go looking for
private funds-- outside money,
as he called it--
in order to fund the
university that he ran.
And in this case, the
donor that he courted
was Nike and its
CEO, Phil Knight,
who was the most illustrious
and successful alum
of the University of Oregon.
Outside of Silicon Valley,
and I suppose outside of here
in Kirkland, a lot
of fun has been
had over Google's old
slogan, Don't Be Evil,
but I think it's
interesting to consider
why a corporation
founded in 1998
might have felt
the need for such
a mantra in the first place.
One possible explanation,
I would argue,
might be suggested by
the passage from my book
that I'm about to read, which
explains a bit about Nike's
reputation at that time.
"The shoes that Nguyen
Thi Thu Phuong died making
were designed at
Nike's headquarters
in Beaverton, Oregon.
The plans for the shoes were
then relayed by satellite
to a computer-aided
manufacturing desk in Taiwan,
where prototypes were
developed and tested.
Once the shoe's
blueprints were approved,
they were sent by
fax to the factory
where Phuong
worked, in Bien Hoa,
northeast of Ho Chi Minh City.
There the shoe's
three main parts--
the outsole, the
midsole, and the upper--
were produced individually,
then assembled
in a labor-intensive process
that was difficult to automate,
and therefore relied
on manual labor.
It was a summer day in 1997,
and Phuong was making midsoles,
carefully trimming away the
excess synthetic material
overflowing from molds that
had just come out of an oven.
Nearby, a co-worker's
sewing machine
suddenly broke down,
spraying metal parts
across the factory floor.
A piece of shrapnel
pierced Phuong's heart,
killing her instantly.
She was 23.
Nike's response to the young
woman's death was to boldly
claim, 'We don't make shoes.'
Knight and his team of
self-proclaimed shoe dogs,
whose origin story was tied to
making prototype soles in Bill
Bowerman's waffle
iron, now claimed
they were little more
than the designers
and marketers of shoes
made by other companies.
The backlash against
Nike amplified just
as the company was expanding
its retail operations
by opening its upscale
Niketown retail outlets
around the country.
Picketers and news cameras
showed up at store openings,
including one in San Francisco,
where NFL wide receiver Jerry
Rice was assailed with questions
about sweatshops and child
labor.
This was a major
problem for Knight,
who planned to open three
more Niketown shops in 1998.
They weren't just retail
outlets, but brand awareness
generators that helped
increase Nike's sales
at other retailers,
like Foot Locker.
And key Niketown locations,
like the one in London,
would help give the
company the foothold
it needed as it
sought to make inroads
into the European soccer market.
Michael Jordan faced his own
tough questions about Nike
sweatshops during
a press conference,
but even worse things
were in store for Knight,
who learned that documentary
filmmaker Michael Moore was set
to release a new film
'The Big One,' focused
on Nike's misadventures
in offshore manufacturing.
Wall Street took notice,
and throughout 1997 it
was not uncommon to find
stock analyst reports filled
with summaries of
the latest news
reports on the condition
of Nike's factories
throughout Asia, and
the extent to which
the company and its
shareholders were exposed.
For the first time
in years, analysts
began downgrading Nike stock
and lowering its expectations
for the company's outlook.
When Knight at last looked
outside his company for help,
he turned to afford a firm
called GoodWorks International,
owned by Andrew Young, a former
mayor of Atlanta who had also
been the US ambassador
to the United Nations.
He hired GoodWorks to evaluate
Nike's operations in 1997,
and Young himself
went to Asia to meet
with some of Nike's suppliers
and contractors there.
When Young issued his report on
Nike's use of overseas labor,
it was hard to imagine that
Dusty Kidd and the rest
of Nike's public relations
staff could have done more
to polish what was
clearly a rotten apple.
Knight was so pleased
with Young's conclusions
that he took out full-page
newspaper advertisements
highlighting them.
'It is my sincere belief that
Nike is doing a good job,' one
advertisement in 'The
New York Times' read.
'But Nike can and
should do better.'
Knight was also pleased
with another aspect
of Young's evaluation.
While third-party monitoring
of Nike's overseas factories
was a good idea,
it should be left
to a company like his own firm,
GoodWorks, Young felt, and not
to global labor and human
rights organizations.
The benefits of this
approach for Nike
were evident from
the amount of control
the company was able to exert
over the Young report, which
completely ignored the key
issues of wages for factory
workers.
Young had also relied
entirely on Nike interpreters
during his 10 days of
interviews with the workers
making Nike shoes at
factories in Asia.
The widely criticized
Andrew Young report
was further undermined
in November 1997,
when a disgruntled
Nike employee leaked
some highlights from a
series of formal audits
Nike had commissioned
Ernst & Young to prepare.
The accounting
firm had, in fact,
been auditing Nike factories
in Indonesia since 1994,
but Knight had managed to
keep these less forgiving
assessments quiet up until the
November 1997 leak of an Ernst
& Young report
recommending improvements
to a factory just north of
Ho Chi Minh City in Vietnam.
The factory where Nguyen Thi Thu
Phuong died making Nike shoes,
Ernst & Young found, did
not have safety equipment
or training for its
workers, who were forced
to work more hours
than allowed by law,
making them more likely to
become injured or killed
on the job.
For months, Nike
had known exactly
which measures needed to
be taken to prevent others
from dying like Phuong had.
But instead of
focusing on solutions
for the problems Ernst & Young
had found at its factories
in Asia, Nike instead promoted
the much rosier portrait
that Andrew Young had
painted in his report, which
was conducted the same
summer that Phuong died--
a picture of a
company doing its best
and coming up a little
short, as even the best
athletes sometimes do; a
story rather than a solution;
or, as Jordan might say,
a dream to be sold rather
than a problem to be fixed."
And from here I'm going to shift
into a passage that describes
this burgeoning campus protest
movement that was developing
at the time, that was centered
around anti-sweatshop labor,
the anti-sweatshop
labor movement.
It's sort of hard
to imagine now.
I mean, we're seeing a
resurgence in campus protest
movements now, I think,
centered on things like the NRA,
#MeToo, issues like this.
We're seeing a return
to campus protest.
But for a long time,
basically since the wars
in Iraq and Afghanistan
started, campus protest
has been largely about anti-war,
because we've basically been
at war ever since.
But prior to that, this
anti-sweatshop movement
was a big deal.
And it was, in fact, maybe the
most successful mass protest
movement in America since
the anti-apartheid movement.
And here's what it looked like
at the University of Oregon.
"On the afternoon
of April 4, 2000,
six University of
Oregon students
locked arms and
blocked the entrance
to Johnson Hall, a stately
100-year-old building that
housed the offices of the
school's top administrators.
A heaving mass of
protesters came
with them, swarming the
six stone columns framing
the entrance to the
red brick facade, which
sits on 295 immaculately
kept acres of campus,
bordered by the Willamette River
and stippled with some 3,000
trees.
From the window of his office,
Dave Frohnmayer could see
the messages students
had written to him,
spelled out on the sidewalk
in bright pink chalk,
'Take a hike, Nike,' with the
company's signature swoosh logo
standing in for its name.
It was the University of
Oregon's first major student
sit-in since the anti-war
demonstrations that
began in 1969 and carried on
into the following year, when
four members of a
self-described student women's
militia hurled buckets of fresh
animal blood on army recruiters
while chanting
slogans of protest
against the My Lai
Massacre in Vietnam.
Oregon's campus protests
against the war in Vietnam
intensified just as
Frohnmayer arrived
at the University
as a law professor
and legal counsel to then
president Robert D. Clark.
In many ways, Clark had
it easier than Frohnmayer.
Had he sided with protesters
and kicked recruiters
off his campus, he'd only
have angered the US Army.
Frohnmayer, on the
other hand, had
to worry about
angering Phil Knight.
In the three decades since
Frohnmayer had moved to Eugene,
the college by the
river had grown
to become Eugene's
largest employer,
with 10,000 Oregonians
depending on the school
for their livelihood.
And in the handful
of years since Knight
had begun paying for
new buildings on campus,
he'd become more than
just an important booster
for Oregon athletics.
He was the school's most
important benefactor,
which made him, in
a sense, the town's
most important benefactor.
On campus, not everyone was
comfortable with the influence
Knight seemed to have, or
the school's renewed focus
on athletics over academics.
These developments
coincided with a moment
in which student activism
was regaining its voice,
particularly when it came to
labor and human rights issues.
And Nike, which was
facing intensifying calls
for independent monitoring
at its overseas factories,
had a target on its back.
It was a major problem for
Knight's company, which
was losing ground to Adidas
and couldn't afford to give up
its position as the shoe
and apparel supplier
to America's top universities.
Nike's war to maintain its grip
on America's college campuses
began in earnest
in late 1997, when
students at the University
of North Carolina
protested the
company's $7.2 million
endorsement deal
with the school.
In early 1998, the movement
gained a powerful voice
in Jim Keady, an
assistant soccer coach
at St. John's
University, who decided
to publicly quit his job
rather than wear the Nike gear
his school's contract demanded.
'I don't want to be a billboard
for a company that would do
these things,' Keady said
of Nike's overseas labor
practices.
In 1999, the pressure
on Nike intensified
after student
activists took over
buildings at Duke, Georgetown,
the University of Michigan,
and the University of
Wisconsin, and staged sit-ins
at many other schools.
Just before Christmas in 2000,
student carolers strode through
the halls of Harvard
University's administrative
building singing
'Away in a Sweatshop.'
It was becoming more than just
an image problem for Nike.
When a factory worker was fired
by one of Nike's contractors
in Honduras, student
activists organized
such effective protests
that the company
was forced to rehire the woman.
Nike's university shoe
and apparel contracts
became the common battleground
shared by activists concerned
over issues ranging from
sweatshop labor and China trade
policy to college athletics,
which increasingly took
precedence over
academic excellence
at schools around the country.
And it wasn't just contracts
with athletics departments
that were under fire.
Nike was facing
significant backlash
over the branded apparel it
had so successfully marketed
to ordinary university students
through its College Colors
program.
'It really is quite
sick,' said Tom Wheatley,
a student and organizer at
the University of Wisconsin.
'14-year-old girls are working
100-hour weeks and earning
poverty-level wages to
make my college T-shirts.
That's unconscionable.'
At a growing number of
campuses around the country,
organizations like United
Students Against Sweatshops
and the Movement for
Democracy and Education
collaborated with the National
Labor Committee and the Worker
Rights Consortium.
The student-led WRC proved
to be especially effective
at recruiting universities to
the cause, first by protesting
and then by lobbying students,
faculty, and university
presidents to sign
its pledge censoring
corporations for using
sweatshop labor to produce
athletic apparel and shoes.
By April 2000, the
months-old organization
had already gained the backing
of 45 different universities
around the country, which
frustrated and angered Knight,
because joining the WRC meant
publicly criticizing Nike
for failing to allow, among
other things, surprise
inspections at its
overseas factories
where its shoes were made.
Knight, meanwhile, was trying to
pressure Nike's partner schools
into ignoring the WRC, steering
them toward the relatively
toothless Fair
Labor Association,
which had executives
from various apparel
companies sitting on its board.
The campus wars came to
a head in April of 2000,
when Knight abruptly
ended negotiations
to renew his company's
sports equipment
contract with the University
of Michigan, a deal that
would have been worth
as much as $26 million,
making it the largest of its
kind up until that point.
Michigan's administrators
and athletics departments
stood firm, issuing an unusually
pointed statement aimed
at Nike's retaliatory tactics.
'Nike has chosen to strike
out at universities committed
to finding appropriate ways
to safeguard and respect human
rights,' the school said."
And I'll stop that
section there.
This basically leads
up to the situation
that I described at the
beginning of my talk,
which I think you can infer
from what I've said so far how
that situation turns out, and
who comes out the victor when
students or faculty, or
even administrators, go up
against a big time corporate
benefactor like Phil Knight.
But I want to talk briefly,
before opening it up
to questions from you guys,
about how the book came
to be in the first place,
and sort of the ground
that it covers, because it
didn't start out as a book.
It actually began in
the spring of 2014
as just a couple of
newspaper articles
for "The New York Times."
The sports editor for
"The New York Times,"
a guy named Jason
Stallman, sent me to Eugene
to cover this scandal
that was unfolding there
at the University of
Oregon, where a freshman
had reported that she had been
raped by three of the school's
basketball players.
And it was unusual and worth the
coverage, I thought, because--
the reason I heard about
it in the first place
was because of a
police report that
had been leaked to the press.
And the police report
was two months old,
and I thought, why is this--
why are these guys still playing
basketball, first of all?
I mean, why haven't we heard
anything about this yet?
And the reason,
it turned out, was
because the school had chosen
to treat this girl's report
of being sexually assaulted--
rather brutally, I might add.
It was a very graphic
police report.
They decided to treat this
like a public relations
issue rather than a serious
legal and ethical and moral
issue.
And so I was left with a
lot of questions by the way
the school handled this case.
In the end, they
suspended the players.
The players all went off
to other universities,
and the university
president resigned in shame,
took with him nearly a million
dollars in severance pay.
And meanwhile the student, as
I followed the case for years--
I ended up going off to
Columbia journalism school
later that year, where I
was a fellow at the Stabile
Center for Investigative
Journalism,
and I chose to follow this
as my master's project there.
And as I followed along
with what happened,
things just got worse and worse
for the victim in this case,
for the woman who
filed this report.
I mean, the school really
treated this girl very badly.
One administrator encouraged
her to seek counseling.
They gave all these
interviews in the press
after the story
broke about how they
have all these resources
for students and counseling
available.
So then this girl who filed
this report, and who had it
ignored while the school
allowed these guys
to keep playing basketball
through the NCAA tournament--
and after she went
to counseling,
the person in charge of the
student counseling center,
who herself was a
licensed psychologist,
instructed her subordinates
to steal the notes
from her sessions, from
her therapy sessions,
so that they could
use them against her
in the event of a lawsuit.
And eventually they ended up
settling the whole thing out
of court.
But I learned that
stuff like this goes on,
and it's not rare.
It happens everywhere.
And, as I argue in
the book it's really
compounded when universities
have corporate partners
like Nike and they
become more concerned
with protecting
their brand than they
do with following the rules.
I mean, in this case alone,
state public records laws
were broken.
I think some federal
laws regarding Title IX
and regarding the Clery Act
were also violated, I argue.
So that's sort of how I
came to work on this book.
And what I learned
as I looked back
is that the story is
one that we should all
be paying attention to no
matter what state we live in,
because this--
I thought I was writing--
I told a guy at "The New
York Times" in an interview,
I thought I was writing a book
about something that happened
at the University of Oregon,
and instead, what it turned out
I was writing was a book
about something that's
happening everywhere.
Because this all began for
Oregonians back in 1990,
when they passed this
piece of legislation that
defunded public higher education
and sent university presidents
and administrators scrambling,
looking for outside money.
But it didn't stop with Oregon.
Oregon was just
ahead of the curve.
And so Oregon started
doing that in 1990,
and a few years later, states
are doing it everywhere.
And so now everyone is.
Believe it or not, as
horrible as this all sounds,
this seems attractive to a lot
of university administrators,
because university
presidents tend
to be very short-term
in their thinking.
They're around usually
for four or five years.
And the blueprint for them
is to sort of come in, build
something and put
their name on it
or have their name
associated with it,
and then move on to another
university and a bigger
paycheck.
So for them, I
described in the book,
for example, the
University of Maryland,
where Kevin Plank, the founder
of Under Armour, is an alum.
I mean, they basically look
at this as a blueprint,
as a road to follow.
Yeah, this is great,
because it will
allow us to build some fancy
new buildings on campus.
And meanwhile,
student tuition still
goes up, because when you have
a big time corporate donor
like Phil Knight at
your school, it's
really the equivalent of having
a credit card with a limit
that you just shouldn't have.
It allows universities to
spend well beyond their means,
and they spend on the things
that those donors want,
like a big stadium
or what have you.
And what those donors tend not
to care about is academics,
is--
well, one of the
things that makes
the American public
universities such a great idea
and so good for society
is that it's always
been a path for lower
and middle class people
to work their way up.
I mean, my mother
worked in a cannery
and my father was a
fisherman, and I grew up
in a tiny town in Alaska.
And it's because of a
public state university,
it's because of that access
to an affordable degree
that I was able to
work my way up and get
where I wanted to go.
So this is not just--
this is not some
small thing that's
imperiled when we abandon a
public institution like this
to corporate interests and
allow them to call the shots,
because what we're
abandoning is not
just an important public
institution, but an institution
that really provides in a
way that nothing else can,
I would argue, a path to
upward social mobility.
And so, again, as
I told this guy
at "The New York Times" who
interviewed me, why should
people read this book.
I told him, well, I think now is
the perfect time for Americans
to understand, to
fully understand
the consequences of abandoning
our public institutions
in order to save a few
dollars on our taxes,
and leaving them up
to private interests
to come in and save
them, because that's
what will happen.
I mean, these institutions
aren't just going to fade away.
If we as citizens
aren't interested,
other interests will come
in and will take over,
and will steer the ship.
And we're seeing
in our government
what that's like right now.
But this is a very
in-depth case study
of what that looks
like over time,
and of how that really
infects every aspect
of the institution.
And I guess now I will
start taking some questions,
if you guys have any.
So to repeat the question, how
can students who are protesting
on their campuses
be more effective
and have an impact
when universities
and their benefactors are
trying to manage them, I guess.
And it's interesting.
One of the things--
I mean, I think
one of the reasons
why I talk for a few
chapters about the importance
of this anti-sweatshop
protest movement
is because I think there's a
lot of really valuable lessons
there and there's some
important history there, too.
One of the valuable lessons is
that protesting really works.
I mean, Nike's--
I mean, I'm not going
to go out there and say
Nike is doing everything they
should be doing when it comes
to overseas labor at this point,
but they're doing a lot better.
And they didn't
just wake up one day
and say, oh, we have a moral
obligation to these people that
are dying in Vietnam or
wherever making our shoes.
They did it because the
protesters were just so--
were organizing so
effectively, and part
of the reason they
were so effective
is because there was a
lot of collaboration.
So you had--
I mean, there was
human rights groups,
international human rights
groups collaborating
with American labor
and union groups,
collaborating with
church groups.
I mean, there were some
cases back then where
you had outright
communists organizing
with old church ladies, which
is fascinating to think about.
I mean, you can really
accomplish things
when you can bring together old
church ladies and communists.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, that's really
effective organization.
I argue also in the
book that they were so--
the network they
built up was so strong
that when the wind shifted
and suddenly everyone
started protesting the wars
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
part of the reason those
protests came together
so quickly is because
there were already
these sort of radical
left wing networks at all
these campuses, people who were
on the same page politically.
So even though the--
I mean, you might say,
well, we're still at war,
so what did those protests do?
But they got attention,
and they were big,
and people's voices were heard.
Today, actually, some reviewers
who have read the book
and who have interviewed me have
said, it's kind of a dark book.
Do you think-- are you hopeful?
You talk about all this
bad stuff that goes on.
Do you have any reason for hope?
And I tell them one thing
that makes me hopeful
is this resurgence in the campus
protest movement and the fact
that there does seem to be
this spirit of collaboration
out there where there's
people whose issue is gun
control, collaborating with
people whose issue is raising
the minimum wage or whatever,
or whether it's #MeToo,
or whether it's sort of
just anti-Trump, generally.
But there seems to be
a lot of collaboration.
I think the protests
against the NRA
are especially inspiring,
because that's something
that for years, we've
heard people say,
oh well, I mean, basically,
the left threw in the towel
on that issue, saying it was
impossible, a non-starter.
And all of a sudden
there's these 18
and 19-year-olds really
making the NRA sweat
and really pushing people.
I get emails all the time
from different chapters
of the Democratic Socialists
of America saying,
oh, we'd love to have you
for an event or whatever.
That tells me there's all these
young people out there who
are deeply committed to change
and willing to fight for it,
and they don't have these
same lines in the sand
that we used to,
where we thought,
oh, well, that's
too much to ask for,
so we just won't ask for it.
I mean, they're asking for
socialism, for Christ sakes.
That's something
that no one would
have thought to seriously
ask for a few years ago.
Yep.
So the question is are
there processes or systems
that universities
can have to prevent
against the kinds of abuses
that I describe in the book,
some sort of systemic
ways of dealing
with the problem of
overreach by corporate donors
at universities.
I think there's a few things.
The sort of biggest picture
thing is more of a government
slash society thing,
not a university thing.
And that is that, in addition
to we as citizens recognizing
the value of our
public universities
and supporting them however
we can with our taxes
or what have you,
I think, also, we
should make sure that our
corporations are paying
their fair share of taxes.
And so if a corporation does
need to support a university,
it can do so with its
tax dollars in a way
that's transparent
and that doesn't
lead to these kind
of private fiefdoms
that we see with Nike and
the University of Oregon,
or Under Armor and University
of Maryland, or in Oklahoma
with T. Boone Pickens,
the oil billionaire.
The other thing
is a lot of what I
describe in the book
are abuses of processes
that already are in place.
And so, for instance,
public records law in Oregon
is pretty strong, and it
really demands that the public
be able to scrutinize.
I mean, any public
university, any university
that gets federal funding,
the records are public.
Basically, every record created
that university is public
unless it infringes on a
student's privacy or someone's
medical privacy or personal
privacy or something like this.
So for instance, when a
student reports a rape,
if university
administrators start
talking about that on email,
or text messages on their work
phones, with crisis
communicators and PR
professionals and saying
how do we handle this,
or the day that the police
report of a rape on campus
leaks and they start passing
emails back and forth
saying, oh, my god, what
are we going to do--
those are public records.
Those are records I tried
to get and that they really
fought to hide, because those
records revealed that they were
not thinking about the victim.
They were not thinking
about the student body.
They were thinking about
their image and their brand,
and their paychecks, basically.
And so one thing is
to make sure that we
have strong enforcement for
things like open records laws
and to really demand that
these people follow the rules
and to demand that they--
I mean, not just the
rules, but the law.
Respect the processes that are
in place, because transparency
is the biggest thing
that we can have.
Someone at a luncheon
recently said,
you know, this is why integrity
and leadership matter so much.
And I said, no, I disagree.
Integrity is a gamble.
It's a gamble to bet on
your CEO having integrity.
And everyone's fallible also,
so even people of integrity
can be compromised.
What's important is
transparency and accountability.
Follow-up question.
Big philanthropy, should
there be more oversight.
Yes.
It's tricky, though because--
I think if there
were more oversight--
I mean, I think, yes, there
should be more oversight.
There should be
more accountability.
But I also, I
think we'll see how
generous people really are when
there's actual accountability
and when this stuff is all
out in the open because--
and, again, it goes
back to that tax issue.
Just make corporations
pay their taxes,
because all this valorizing of
billionaires giving money away,
I mean, mostly it's a
tax write off for them.
And mostly their money
comes with strings
attached, as it certainly
does in the cases
that I describe in my book.
So it's a tricky question.
It's a tricky question.
Yes, we should, but
what will happen
to the philanthropy industry?
Because it is an industry
and it is kind of--
I describe it in my book not
as gifts but as investments.
I mean, I think
that's how people--
I think that's how
philanthropy really works, is
it's a kind of investment.
The question is
regarding these students
as employees movement,
this endless controversy
about whether student athletes
ought to be paid or not paid.
I describe in my
book, at some point
I describe how that came to
pass, and basically let me--
yeah.
In fact, I'll just
read this brief passage
about the first sort of rule
book for college football.
And it was decided--
these were decided
on in 1860, so--
sorry.
1869 was this
important game when
Rutgers beat Princeton
that sort of led
to the flowering of
college football.
And then in 1898, "In
February, 1898 Brown University
hosted a conference
focused on, quote,
'the discussion of
questions arising out
of intercollegiate contests
and the objectionable features
connected with them,"
end quote, which
drew delegates from Columbia,
Cornell, Dartmouth, Harvard,
Princeton, and the
University of Pennsylvania.
These delegates argued on a
set of eligibility requirements
known as the Providence
Rules, and they
advanced an idea that
remains among the most
enduring and controversial
aspects of college sports.
'It is obvious,' they
wrote in their report,
'that no student should be
paid for his athletics.'"
OK.
So let me just
read again the name
of the colleges that
decided that it would
be ungentlemanly to pay
student athletes for their work
on behalf of the school,
Columbia, Cornell, Dartmouth,
Harvard, Princeton, and the
University of Pennsylvania.
This is a turn of the
century Ivy League thing.
They were very-- there was this
obsession with what they called
the athletes code of honor.
And the really
funny thing is it--
well, I'll just read on.
After the passage it is
obvious that no student should
be paid for his
athletics, I say,
"Market forces
prevailed, however,
giving college football its
first cheating scandal, just
one year after the Brown
Conference gave it a rulebook.
Desperate to beat rival
school Yale, unable to find
11 men of weight and muscle
among his university's 2,100
male students, Columbia's
head football coach,
George Foster Sanford,
resorted to hiring ringers.
The university tried to pin
the scandal on a departing
assistant coach, but
years later Sanford
would blame his unprecedented
$5,000 coaching salary.
The lure of quick money, the
unexpected pressure that came
with it, and, quote, 'the
virus of the game,' he said,
had nearly destroyed him."
I mean, I think has
anything changed?
I mean, that's sort
of what happens
when you have something,
this institution where
the stakes are so high and
there's so much money pouring
into it, and everyone is
getting paid but the students,
of course there's
going to be corruption.
Of course there is
going to be scandal.
I mean, this corruption,
it's laughable
that the only thing these people
are getting convicted of now
is paying athletes.
I mean, that seems silly to me.
In short, it seems to me that
this system doesn't work.
It's, at best,
deeply hypocritical
and highly unrealistic.
It's going to be rife
with corruption and crime.
If it goes on this way,
they should probably
change the rulebook.
And, by the way, it's not
like the NCAA has ever
changed a rule before.
One thing I discuss in the
book is the whole reason
that Nike and Adidas and
these other shoe and apparel
companies can make all-school
deals with universities
is because Nike did an
end-run around the rules
back in the day, back
in the late '70s.
Up until 1986, there
was no such provision
for having an all-school deal.
So what they did
was Nike realized,
oh, we just buy the coaches.
So they would go
directly to the coach,
pay the coach $5,000
or $10,000, and say,
we're going to pay you.
We're going to give you, Mr.
Basketball Coach, a contract.
We'll pay you $5,000
or $10,000 a year,
and you're going to
exclusively wear Nike shoes.
And, by the way,
we're also going
to give you a free pair of
shoes for-- how many guys
do you have on your team?
OK, that many guys.
And if you let us know
what sizes to get them in,
we'll make sure they're the
right size for the guys.
And if all goes well, we'll give
you the same amount of money
next year, too, and the year
after that, in perpetuity.
And it's like a quarter
of what the coaches--
I mean, in the end, they were
getting more money from Nike
or Adidas, whoever their part
shoe partner was than they
were from their university.
And so that's, by 1986--
They couldn't legally
require the coach
to make his players
wear the shoes,
but if you know that
you're not going
to get that $10,000 next
year unless Nike's happy,
and you know what
will make Nike happy
is to make your
players wear the shoes,
they're going to wear
the shoes, and they did.
And so that's why in 1986,
the NCAA said, screw it.
Let's just commodify the
game and change the rules.
And that's why we
have all-school deals.
They could do something
similar to-- they
could change the rules in
favor of paying players
or something like this.
They just don't have
any incentive to do it,
or they think they don't
have an incentive to do it.
So the question is,
is there a corporation
that has a relationship
with the university
that I think is ideal and
that is some kind of model?
AUDIENCE: Besides Google's.
JOSHUA HUNT: Besides--
besides Google's.
I mean, my book largely focuses
on the relationships that
haven't, that have
spectacularly not worked out.
I mean, Berkeley
and Novartis comes
to mind, Berkeley and
BP Oil, and, of course,
the big apparel and shoemakers.
I think as a journalist,
it's not really
my place to sort
of advise on policy
or think too much about
how things ought to be.
But I do think that--
I do maintain that whatever--
because, look, I
think basically,
I don't subscribe to this myth
of good and bad corporations.
I just don't.
I really do think that's a myth.
And I think that corporations
that act appropriately
are corporations where power
is somewhat evenly distributed,
where there's a good
corporate culture, where there
is incentives to do the
right thing as opposed
to doing the wrong thing,
where diversity and inclusion
are important, and where
there's transparency.
I mean, where there's
transparency and equally
important, accountability--
where those things are
paramount, I think you
just can't go wrong,
because otherwise--
The problem isn't just
what a corporation
might make a university do,
might force a university do.
In Nike's case,
everything from--
I mean, Phil Knight has
had people hired and fired
from the athletics department at
the University of Oregon, which
is crazy.
But it's also about
what universities
might think their corporate
benefactor would want them
to do and how they might
change their behavior
without any direct
cues from someone
that's giving them money.
They might just
say, oh, well, we
don't want this headache
so we'll act this way
or act that way.
That can be really harmful, too.
Say the corporation is doing
their best to do things really
ethically, and, in the
case of this partnership,
things can still go bad if
the university sort of thinks
they need to cover up this
or hide that or make things,
if they're worried
about spooking
the corporate sponsors.
So transparency is key.
And that's tricky with--
so one thing I talk about near
the end of the book is this
thing called the Knight Campus
for Advancing Scientific
Impact, which is, to me, a very
Silicon Valley-sounding sort
of--
it sounds like an incubator or
something-- at the University
of Oregon that's being funded.
It's a billion
dollar campus being
funded with a $500 million
gift from Phil Knight, which
is another thing about
big time philanthropy.
When someone hands
you $500 million
for a billion dollar
project, they're
also handing you a
bill for $500 million,
and it's tough to
raise that money.
And so now the
University of Oregon
is looking into
state bonds and stuff
like that to finish the project.
And a big concern for
me is if they get down
to that last $100 million
that they need, what are you
going to be willing to do if
you're a university president
and you can go out with
a big win or a big loss,
depending on whether you
get this campus completed?
What are you going
to be willing to do
for the person that's going to
put up that last $100 million?
Probably a lot.
And when it comes to--
these issues just
get more complex
because there's not been
any transparency about what
kind of corporate partners are
going to be involved in doing
research at the Knight campus.
But a lot of people
think it's probably going
to be pharmaceutical companies.
I mean, it could be Google
or someone doing AI research.
Whatever the case
may be, there are
loopholes in Oregon's
public records law
which allow people to keep
secret communications that
might infringe on some
kind of trade secret.
That's a big problem
because how do you
protect, how does a
corporation legitimately
protect their trade secrets
without that being abused?
I mean, before long
you've got people
maybe talking about
illegal activities
between some researcher and some
pharmaceutical company head.
Maybe they're trying to
cover up some ill effect that
was discovered through
some study or something.
And they can do it by exploiting
this loophole, by saying,
oh, well, these emails we
won't give to journalists
or to the public
because they might
infringe on trade secrets.
That's concerning.
So, again, transparency
is the thing.
So the question
is, where would I
rank Phil Knight among
all the awful CEOs?
Again, my answer is maybe
a little bit unsexy,
but I don't--
for me, it's not a
matter of corporations
being evil or good.
It's about them being
totally amoral, 100% amoral,
guided by nothing more
than, I mean, maybe loosely,
some founding
principle or some--
I mean, if it's a corporation
that's founded by engineers,
then they're more likely to
have maybe some drive that's--
whether they're obsessed
with AI or whatever
it is, but more or less they're
driven by achieving their goal
and making a lot of money
for their shareholders
while doing it.
Or just making enough money
to keep the boat going.
I mean, look at
Theranos, you know.
So for me it's not really about
like, oh, CEOs are so evil
and corporations are so bad.
It's just that, to my mind,
they will all more or less
do what they can get away with.
And when I say what
they can get away with,
I mean within their
corporate structure,
within their society, within--
I'm really-- my
next book is going
to be about global
counterfeiting
and international
crime, and that's
really connected to the
offshore manufacturing
boom of the 1980s.
And so I'm really obsessed
with that right now,
and I think one of the things
that's interesting about it
to me is these companies, these
multinational corporations that
are all victims of
counterfeiters now.
They've created this
problem for themselves,
because they set up their
manufacturing explicitly
in countries not only
where labor was cheap,
but where there were really
weak protections for workers
so they could just exploit
people to the maximum.
And places where the
rule of law is weak
and they could sort of
push around the government
a little bit.
And, hey, guess what?
You can't push around
China so easily now
as you could maybe
back in the 1980s,
if you're some
American corporation.
So I hesitate to
rank Phil Knight
among all the other
bad guy CEOs out there.
I will say one reason I thought
this book was especially
important to write
now is because there's
this whole generation, I
think, who are growing up
afraid of Facebook
or afraid of--
or they hate Elon Musk.
This sort of anti-corporate
type of person
these days is pretty
focused on tech companies.
The exposes and all that are
mostly about tech companies,
and I think it's
important to remind people
that capitalism is basically
always been this way.
And the way of
protecting civil society
from unchecked capitalism is the
same ways as it's always been.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Why do you
think universities
take this kind of
poisoned money that
has-- because a lot of times
they get these donations that
say if you match half
a billion dollars,
we'll pay the other half.
If they don't have
the money, why do they
take it in the first place?
JOSHUA HUNT: I mean,
the same reason
a company would take some
venture capital if they're
not all the way there, right?
They want to keep going.
They don't want
the party to end.
I mean, maybe they really
believe in their idea,
or maybe they really
believe they can get there.
Maybe they don't.
Either way, now always seems
like a bad time to stop,
I think, to people,
whether you're in tech
or whether you're in
the university world.
In the case of
university administrators
and in the University of Oregon,
in the case of the University
of Oregon, in
particular, they've
been bailed out so
many times by taxpayers
that I think they're
just used to, oh, we'll
get the money from the
taxpayers if we need to.
Basically, whatever Phil
Knight doesn't pay for
and whatever they can't get
other donors to shore up
the money for-- which is hard,
by the way, because if you've
got to raise $500 million for
something called the Knight
Campus, I mean, no one else is
getting their name on there.
There's less of an
incentive for people
to give big money, big dollar
gifts to a project like that
unless they have a specific
research interest or something.
And so what they do is the
president of the University
of Oregon, Michael
Schill, is already
begging the
legislature in Oregon
to issue these state bonds,
which come with hefty interest
payments.
And that's basically
their answer is,
oh, give us $100 million
more in state bonds, please.
And the legislature has so
far been fairly skeptical.
I mean, they've given them some
of the money they've asked for
but not all of it.
So, again, the
question for me becomes
when it comes down
to the point where
they need to raise that last
$200 million, $100 million,
what are they going
to be willing to do?
I fear to find out
what the answer is.
Or, at the very least, I hope
we find out what the answer is,
fearful as it may be.
AUDIENCE: Let's thank
Josh for coming.
[APPLAUSE]